Just got my vitamin D test back and it was 55.8. I'm taking three vitamin 80k
complete or 80k avail. Do I need to increase my dose? So 55.8 I wouldn't
consider that low. That's I would not add any more vitamin D if this was me. But
it does seem odd that how could my vitamin D is only 55.8 and I'm taking three
of these a day. I think that that's 15,000 I use a day. That's insane. Well
that does point to the possibility that I didn't look at this person's
genetics to review that but the the 80R gene defect the VDR gene defect
vitamin D receptor gene defect. If you have that defect in your genes that can
decrease the availability of vitamin D to be absorbed that is a big
possibility. Good items normally vitamin D. Now people can have vitamin D
deficiencies that could for other reasons too if they had their gallbladder
reboot they don't absorb their fat very well. They don't break down fat very
well. Vitamin A, D and K and E are all fat soluble vitamins that means you don't
break down those nutrients very well. You don't absorb those very well. So
there's other reasons why a person could have low vitamin D even if they're
their consuming vitamin D supplementations they can have very damaged God
there's other reasons why you might absorb any vitamin D but those are some
possibilities but even all that said 55.8 would not be in my vote considered low.
Yeah we'd really like to have cancer patients be 50 to 150 and in that range I
guess that would be considered a little low but I wouldn't change anything
based upon that 55.8 can be just fine. Second part of the question if I was to
stop taking faslodex. So faslodex is a drug given for ERPR positive
cancers it is selective estrogen receptor disrupter classification of drugs so
it helps get rid of bad estrogens you could say that's the purpose of taking that
drug in most women that are have a breast cancer that's either ER or and or PR
and or PR to positive that may be recommended for them to take. This first
let's ask you if I stop taking the drug would I do a cheek swab to see which
supplements I would need it that would be most appropriate yes do it a
cheek swab would be most appropriate. I have ERPR positive her to negative right
now I'm taking clear dim so clear dim is a dim product that helps pull out bad
estrogens I have astro clear on head astro clear is a lignin product that helps pull
out bad estrogens is there something I could start before stop taking that I
would say before you stop taking that I can't tell you to stop taking that or
start taking a drug but if you're going to make that decision to get another
cheek swab test we have several other good products that can help with this
issue now phasol X is a little bit different class of drugs it helps pull bad
estrogens off the estrogen receptor the only thing from a nutraceutical
standpoint that will help dislodge bad estrogens from the estrogen receptor is
fermented soy not just soy it's got to be fermented soy the only product of
fermented soy out there right now allergy research used to have a fermented soy
chewable they discontinued that the only fermented soy product out there right
now it's the highland product so highland is the name of the product is called
or halen 951 that's the name of the product I think that's how I think that's how you smell it
maybe it's 8 and no it doesn't look right I think that's how you smell it but I will test you
for that if you do a cheek swab that is this is the dosage of that is what we really want to check
if we're going to use that if you call highland and you ask them about the dosage and
told them you have cancer they say you drink a whole bottle it's a little eight-ounce bottle
drink a whole bottle a day well these are you know this product is like 50 some dollars a bottle
we have found Sir Tessie that people don't need a whole bottle they can take one or two or three or four
or five tablespoons as of the bottle last them you know a week or three days it's a little bit less
expensive it's not wasted